Chicago just recorded its deadliest
weekend of the year with 66 shot and 12
killed in just a 63 hour period
including a boy riding his bike and a 14
year old in - 17 year old girls just
standing on the sidewalk we have a heavy
heart our souls are burdened what
happened this weekend did not happen in
every neighborhood in Chicago but it is
unacceptable to happen in any
neighborhood of Chicago well so far this
year 1,785 have been shot in Chicago and
318 killed now believe it or not
shootings are actually down 30% from
2017 and murders are down 25% but still
those figures are well above what
Chicago experienced earlier in the
decade in 2011 when Democratic Mayor
Rahm Emanuel was elected there were 436
murders in Chicago by 2016 that number
had ballooned to 771 a 77 percent
increase and while 2017 was down from
that high-water mark it still saw a
devastating 650 slangs now as you might
imagine there's enormous political
pressure now on a manual to offer
solutions to this heartbreaking cycle
it's about time with that election just
months away he responded today sounding
more like Tom's soul than an Obama
liberal you can talk about the weather
but the weather didn't pull the trigger
and you could talk about jobs and they
count but in parts of the city where
there aren't jobs people did not pull a
trigger there are too many guns on the
street too many people with criminal
records on the street and there is a
shortage of values about what is right
what is wrong what is acceptable what is
condoned and what is condemned I can't
believe I'm saying this but I'm that
he's right of course policing an
Economic Opportunity matter they met her
quite a bit but are those the factors
that are definitive of course not in
2017 the victims of homicide in Chicago
or 76% african-american and a
disproportionate number of the
assailants arrested were also black
primarily male so what's the cause well
if you ask a leftist or the
intellectuals who dominate our
universities they'll blame crime on
institutional racism or maybe poverty
but as economist Tom Sol wrote just a
few years ago after the Ferguson riots
you cannot take any people of any color
and exempt them from the requirements of
civilization without ruinous
consequences to them and to society at
large murder rates among black males
were going down repeat down during much
of the limit the much lamented 1950s
while it went up after the much
celebrated 1960s reaching levels more
than double what they had been before
most black children were raised in
two-parent families prior to the 1960s
but today the great majority of black
children are raised in one parent
families now to put it a little bit more
specifically in 1950 17% of black
children lived in single-parent
households at that point black labor
participation rate exceeded that of
whites but today 70% of black children
live in one parent households and that
number is pretty much reversed now moms
do their best of course and they're
heroic but especially in dangerous areas
boys without fathers or male role models
often get
oktin with really bad people remember
this video from Baltimore a mother
urging her child very aggressively
during the Freddie gray riots
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's actually a mother's love maybe
she has some four-letter words but she
could have saved his life that day and
remember Barack Obama's my brother's
keeper initiative it was launched in
2014 and it started out as a way to
assist at-risk boys mostly of color in
the first year he raised 300 million in
corporate donations to help get young
men jobs through mentoring and other
work fairs work projects no real measure
yet of the program's real impact but to
the extent that it stresses hard work
and personal responsibility I think it's
great that's not being nonchalant I
started to carry him by muscle about
about my grades and the difference
between a eight and a beat
I started demanding more I myself I know
experience excellence is is is possible
and I need to strive for that too often
however the social justice warriors fall
into the grievance trap of excusing
rather than punishing what ends up being
criminal behavior now remember the
looting and the violence that we saw in
Ferguson in Baltimore a few years ago
during what we're supposed to be
protests about the deaths of Michael
Brown and Freddie gray well President
Obama used a my brother's keeper event
to provide context to almost to explain
away the violence some communities have
consistently had the odds stacked
against them that there's a tragic
history in this country that has made it
tougher for some that sense of
unfairness and of powerlessness that's
helped fuel some of the protests that
we've seen in places like Baltimore and
Ferguson in too many places in this
country black boys and black men latino
boys Latino men they experience being
treated differently by law enforcement
I'm sure a lot of them do but at some
point
this becomes race-baiting and the king
of this is al sharpton remember his
contribution to stemming the violence in
Chicago his contribution was renting an
apartment in the city for some period of
time in 2013
[Applause]
I'm pretty sure after we rented the
apartment things got worse but I'm
surprised that didn't do the trick great
idea
look I don't doubt that young people
living in the Englewood or the West
Garfield Park neighborhoods of Chicago
can feel really hopeless and even
distrustful against the police but the
real problem isn't aggressive policing
the real problem are gangs with
memberships that have become
generational young boys without fathers
or any male role models anyone who cares
about them who's a male are too often
sucked into the cults of criminality
Rudy Giuliani the former mayor of New
York who knows a thing or two about
cleaning up a city thinks it's time to
show the man they once called Rambo the
door tweeting Chicago murders are direct
result of one-party democratic rule for
decades policing genius Jerry he meant
Garry McCarthy can do for Chicago what I
did for New York City he was one of the
architects of CompStat it slashed
homicide over 70% tens of thousands of
lives saved well it's true that citizens
most affected seem to be growing very
weary of a Manuel's political dance ron
emmanuel first of all is a con man his
old job is to keep black folks about it
no he doesn't care about anybody but the
people in his neighborhood and his
family opposition of mayor emanuel
obama's protege it's been building for
many reasons part of it the school's the
crime now and remember how proud he was
about this Chicago was a sanctuary city
before anybody knew what sanctuary city
met
this coordinates that we are defending
in the federal court is consistent with
that value system in not only it gives
honor and import to our past it actually
shines a bright light to the future that
we have together as a city well that's
not going over so well on the south side
he cares more about non-citizens African
Americans with citizens and I ask us to
build this country you got some good
things but I think he don't step up and
come to the people where the crime is
you know I'm saying the crime is on the
south side and the west side and there's
the abysmally low percentage of
murderers brought to justice under his
leadership in 2017 the police solved
only 114 of the 650 murders that
occurred in the same year that's 17.5%
only in the early 1990s that figure was
60% no wonder people on the south side
are frustrated so many of promise to try
to help Chicago but few of delivered
solutions maybe because hard truths are
uncomfortable and maybe because
sometimes they're not politically
correct now I've been saying since the
campaign of 2016 that we need to see
more bold thinking conservatives in the
inner cities of this country
the risk is not in showing up the risk
is in not showing up solutions not
politics are what is needed I have to
make sure that President Trump
recognized that not everyone believes
that Chicago is a Trump free zone if
he's serious about helping the people in
Chicago especially on the west side of
Chicago I accept his help we can't turn
any help away we have to make sure that
people understand that criminals cannot
have their way with our streets
but if Chicago Police Department and all
the other law enforcement can't do it we
should seek out the help every day
radicals claim that President Trump is
racist
now as someone who's known him for no 15
years or so I can tell you that is 100%
false and it's a slanderous and
defamatory charge meant to deflect
attention from liberals own abject
failures in leading urban America
Trump's booming economy is benefiting
African Americans and Latinos and all
Americans who wish to better themselves
the one thing we do know racial
hucksters do not have the answers to
prevent another weekend just like we saw
in Chicago and that's the angle